just under three months after the shock
siege of the u.s capitol building
a car ramming outside it has left d.c on
the back foot with one police officer
dead and another in hospital
security in washington has been
ratcheted up again in the wake of the
attack
the suspect was shot dead after stepping
out of his vehicle and brandishing a
knife the officer who died in the attack
has been identified as william evans a
capital policeman of 18 years
president biden has sent his heartfelt
condolences to the officer's family
former pentagon analyst michael malouf
says the latest incident will result in
an even
larger security presence in washington
dc well into the future
the initial concern was this could have
been a decoy
and immediately the rest of the capital
went under further lockdown and also
has uh they've also done the same thing
for government buildings just in case
this might have been a decoy ultimately
but so far nothing else has happened it
could have been just a test
uh if people who have intentions of
hitting the capitol will look upon this
as a lesson learned
on what to do or what not to do and how
to go about this but i think that this
latest episode just reinforces
especially if it was done by a lone
a lone wolf that the they're going to
have to maintain their
their security presence and actually
beef up security
because of the sensitivities of what's
going on in the
in the capital area especially on
capitol hill
and the vulnerability of congressmen and
senators they're going to maintain
security for an indefinite period of
time
you